Jennifer Lawrence and Chris Pratt reveal
what they love about each other you
clean up pretty good yourself
[Music]
you guys have been traveling together a
lot too what is one endearing how that
you've noticed about each other and what
is one may be less than endearing happy
I bet he doesn't love flying with me I'm
not the best flier I'm not the calmest
person like we hit a little turbulence
and then she'll serve you darted
shouting we were very limited towards
the earth
no there were gonna be no survivors
there was she was like pilots pilots
that sound is no one gonna make noise
like they're focusing goes like what am
i focusing on focus so I bet he doesn't
like flying with me but we both the
thing we both love about each other is
that we make each other laugh that's how
we get through that's it our long nights
yeah it's true
we laughed we laughed a lot on this one
but yeah yeah thank you thanks so we'll
just sue the rest of this interview
without her
yeah just crap I think it's really funny
I the funniest part was I was genuinely
not aware of it for a while like a
shocking amount of time because I don't
pay any attention to the internet and
all my friends by now not know not to
talk to me about the internet so I
didn't know for a while so when I found
out of his 3 to 4 times as funny 5 times
maybe yeah really hilarious by the time
I actually saw like there are many
pictures to scroll through I was like
this one and then like I remember taking
that photo okay that was hilarious